[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for "The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
We recently released the
first production ready version
of Oboe, a C++ library for
building real-time audio apps.
Oboe provides the lowest
possible audio latency
across the widest range
of Android devices.
Example code and a video
are on the post linked
in the description below.
The AndroidDevSummit kicks-off
on November 7th, broadcasting
live, from the Computer
History Museum,
in Mountain View, California.
It will be two days of
deep, technical sessions
from the Android
engineering team,
with over 30 sessions
livestreamed.
Links, including information
on sessions and livestream,
are on the post.
Google Cloud Next
London was awesome.
There is a link and the session
videos in the description
below.
And here are a few
of the announcements.
Container-native load balancing
for applications running
on Google Kubernetes Engine and
Kubernetes on Compute Engine
is now available.
Stackdriver Incident
Response and Management, IRM,
on Google Cloud Platform,
is now available in alpha.
We're adding enhancements,
to Cloud Spanner's SQL
capabilities, to make it
easier to read and write
data in Cloud Spanner
databases using SQL,
and use off-the-shelf
drivers and tooling.
Cloud Spanner's API now supports
INSERT, UPDATE, and DELETE SQL
statements.
We're also offering
Key Visualizer,
so you can see key access
patterns in heatmap format
to optimize your
Cloud Bigtable schemas
for improved performance.
There are some Cloud Storage
updates that give you even more
control over how and
where your data is stored,
including the new dual-regional
option for replicating data,
Nearline and Coldline
data are now geo-redundant
in multi-regional locations, the
new Cloud Storage C++ library,
and more.
Several new Apigee capabilities
are now generally available,
including Apigee API
monitoring, Apigee extensions,
and Apigee hosted targets.
We're releasing a
TensorFlow package
for active question answering--
a research project that
investigates using
reinforcement learning
to train artificial agents
for question answering.
ActiveQA interacts with QA
systems using natural language,
with the goal of
providing better answers.
Details and a link to the
GitHub projects are on the post.
New features and
major changes coming
to Chrome DevTools in Chrome
71 include the abilities
to hover over a live expression,
to highlight a Domino, store
Dominoes as global variables,
picture-in-picture breakpoints,
and more.
Check them all out on the post.
Flutter Live is happening on
December 4th at the Science
Museum in London.
This is a worldwide
celebration of Flutter
that will include announcements,
live demos, and more.
The event will be optimized
for online viewers,
with viewing parties
happening around the world
So make sure you
head on to the site
to save the date and sign-up
to watch the livestream.
To provide additional
assurances for users,
we recently announced new
policies focused on Gmail APIs.
They'll help ensure
appropriate access, how
data may not be used, how data
must be secured, and more.
The policies go into
effect on January 9, 2019.
More details are
available in the post.
Over the next few
months, we'll start
showing each Google Account
permission that an app
requests, one at a time,
within its own dialogue
instead of presenting
all permissions
in a single dialogue.
Users will have the abilities
to grant or deny permissions,
individually.
To prepare for
this change, there
are a number of actions
you should take,
within your app, which are
outlined in the post linked
in the description below.
Please remember to Like,
Subscribe, and Share.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for "The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching.
And I'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: This is "Dev Show,"
with Florina, scene one,
take one.
[CLICK]